so I had a thought I do have those on
occasion doesn't have merit very often
but I do have them we've been talking
over the last few days about this story
of the the Sentinelese in India they're
the Stone Age tribe on an island off the
coast of India uncontacted which means
the government the Indian government has
set up a force field around them and
made it illegal for anyone to go and let
them know that the rest of human
civilization exists so as you heard they
murdered a missionary who tried to come
and speak to them last week they they
shot him full of arrows then put a rope
around his neck and dragged him until he
died now the government is trying to
recover the body of this poor guy but
the tribesman won't let won't let anyone
get close to the island to just get the
guys body back and the thing is the
missionary is not the first person that
these people have murdered they also
killed two fishermen in 2006 who
accidentally drifted close to the island
now these men had no intention of
invading the island they weren't trying
to do any they just drifted close to the
island and they were shot full of arrows
and murdered now I have to depart from
what is apparently the majority opinion
about these cases I actually don't think
it's okay for anyone to commit murder
even if you're in a primitive tribe I
you know I'm not in favor of murder for
anyone I don't think anyone should be
able to do it I don't care if you live
in a in a tribe if you live in a city
I think murder is wrong for everybody
that's just me there they are killing
innocent people spent now if you want to
say well the the missionary he knew what
it was getting into and he I still don't
think it's okay to kill him I mean I
don't think that's okay but what about
the fishermen they just drifted close to
the island so there it's so taking be
murdered too um again call me crazy I
just I don't think it's cool I'm not
okay with murder I just personally but
that's not my point what's
interesting it's the timing of this
story this the timing of this story
highlights a really curious contrast and
I want to call attention to it because
as this drama has unfolded in India with
this with this tribe you have also the
migrant Caravan down on the southern
border and you have our government using
physical means though non-lethal but
using physical means to repel people who
are trying to invade our country
illegally now here's where the the
interesting contrast comes into play
because the people who say it's
perfectly justified for this tribe to
kill anyone who comes to their Island at
all those people they are the same ones
in many cases who say that it's some
kind of great evil if we physically
prevent illegal immigrants from coming
to our country now I want you to really
think about that the Sentinelese can
shoot you full of arrows put a rope
around your neck murder you if you so
much as drift close to their island but
we're not allowed to take any physical
measures whatsoever to deal with the
people who come illegally to our country
that that's the position that a large
number of people have taken and it just
makes no sense the response to this
point usually goes something like this
someone will say well they're a
primitive tribe and they don't know any
better are you saying that we should be
held to the same standard as a primitive
tribe shouldn't we be held to a higher
standard
well well first of all no I'm not I'm
not saying that we should be that we
should hold ourselves to that standard
because they murder people who come
close to them I'm not saying that we
should kill illegal immigrants I'm not
advocating that I don't think anyone is
advocating that and I'm especially not
saying that we should kill people who
come to our country just to visit which
is what which is what the Sentinelese do
so no I'm not talking about the same
standard but it isn't this this is the
bigotry of low expectations on steroids
you are setting the bar extreme
only high for us okay you're saying that
we should be so peaceful and so
enlightened and so progressive and so
welcoming that we can't even use any
physical means at all even non-lethal
means to deal with whole hordes of
people who are trying to bum rush our
border so that's what you're saying for
us but then you're putting the bar so
low for these tribesmen your bet you're
putting the bar so low that it's under
the earth you're you're burying the bar
under the earth and you're saying well
for them they can murder whoever they
want you know it it just seems like this
is this is the height of racism that's
what the bigotry of low expectations is
and usually the bigotry of low
expectations it's usually it's it's it
is a form of bigotry normally found
among liberal white people where in an
attempt to be enlightened and an attempt
to be progressive and multicultural
they'll say they'll they'll say well
yeah you know we we hold ourselves to a
certain standard but you know pointing
off to some other race or culture well
we can't expect them back the same way
because you know we can't expect that of
them that's racism that is horrible
racism and in the case of these
primitive tribe people you're basically
treating them like animals you may as
well compare them to a bear mulling a
camper in the forest somewhere well they
don't know any better this is this just
this is just what they do they don't
know any better it that's again that is
that is incredibly racist in an effort
to have these enlightened attitudes
towards these people you are
dehumanizing them you are holding them
to no standard whatsoever you're saying
that even don't murder is too high of a
bar for them to get over and I find that
extremely racist and what is this
assumption I know people have said well
they don't you know they someone's
coming to their Island and they don't
know why the persons
so what else are they supposed to do
well for anyone else on earth we would
say yeah look if someone comes to your
property or you know comes to your house
and that might make you a little bit
wary but you can't just kill them right
away especially if they if they if they
don't appear to be threatening if they
don't have a weapon or anything killing
them shouldn't be the first thing you do
if they're walking up you're if you see
somebody walking up you're you're you
know the the path to your front door you
can't just murder them right away and we
expect everyone to kind of know that
because we expect everyone to have a
certain to value human life and to
understand that human life is valuable
and so you can't just go around killing
people the drop of a hat we here's the
thing we expect everyone to intuitively
not not just because they've been told
by the government we expect everyone to
intuitively know that you can't just go
around killing people yet for these this
primitive tribe what we're saying is no
well they have no knowledge of that well
how do you know they have no knowledge
of that they're human beings how do you
know that they have no concept of that
it's wrong to just go kill people and
and to make that assumption is so racist
I just uh
it seems because I am NOT racist I hold
these people to the same standard I
would hold anyone else to and so if
someone drifts close to your island you
shouldn't kill them it's not okay to
kill them it's just not but what what's
the principle here okay if if we're not
being racist and yet we're still
basically defending the way the north
senator Lee's deal with with so-called
intruders if we're not being racist then
there has to be some principle and the
principle that I that I that I hear from
people is well they have a right to
defend their country even though the
island is not their country it's
actually belongs to India but in any
case they have a right to defend their
land and their home and it's illegal to
go there anyway so you know that's the
principle these are broads
these are statements of principle a
right to defend their home against
evaders that's a principle so if that's
the principle why shouldn't we fall
under the same principle why should we
be exempt if they have a right to defend
their home against invaders why don't we
and I'm not saying that we defend it by
using lethal force I'm not I'm not
saying that at all but if they can use
lethal force can't we use non-lethal
force at least so when you say they have
a right to defend their home I agree I
don't think I don't agree with the
murdering personally I may be the only
person in the country apparently feels
this way but I don't agree with the
murdering part but I agree in principle
with defending your home and your
country and guess what we have the same
right so it's just I can if you're going
to defend the way that these tribesmen
deal with anyone who even comes close to
appearing that they might invade or
intrude or whatever if you're going to
defend that yet tell us yet tell the
American government that we're wrong for
defending our borders I cannot think of
any explanation for that dichotomy other
than racism on your part if it's not
racism then there should be certain
basic principles that we all you know
that apply to all of us and if the
principle is you can defend your home
defend your country well then you
shouldn't have any problem with the way
that the government is defending our
home in our country down on the southern
border all right I wanted to make
mention of this story reading from the
report in The Daily wire according to a
Stanford educated Chinese researcher the
first ever genetically edited babies
twin girls whom he altered to be more
resistant to HIV infection were born
this month a month in action that is
being condemned as unethical by some of
his fellow scientists in an Associated
Press reports
published Monday the scientist said that
he helped design the world's first
genetically altered babies who were born
this month I'm trying to get to the okay
so the AAP provides some more details on
the process the gene editing occurred
during IVF or lab dish fertilization
first sperm was washed quote-unquote to
separate it from semen the fluid where
HIV can lurk a single sperm was placed
into a single egg to create an embryo
then the gene editing tool was added
when the embryos were three to five days
old a few cells were removed and checked
for editing couples could choose whether
to use edited or unedited embryos for
pregnancy attempts in all 16 of 22
embryos were edited and 11 embryos were
used in six implant attempts before the
twin pregnancy was achieved alright um
hopefully you followed all that and you
understand how that works because I
totally understand it of course so
there's a lot of unknown about this and
many scientists have pointed out that we
don't really know the long-term effects
we don't know what effect this might
have on the kids we don't even know if
this attempt will be successful in terms
of preventing HIV so there's a lot that
that's that's unknown this was
essentially well not essentially this
was human experimentation this scientist
was experimenting on these human embryos
and so these these twin babies are like
guinea pigs basically and what's so
worrisome is that it seems to open
Pandora's box to lead to a kind of
Gattaca situation where babies can be
designed to suit the specifications of
the parents now some people will look at
this kind of stuff and they'll say well
so what what's wrong with that why not
experiment and tinker and create babies
that are perfected by science well I
think there are a lot of ethical
concerns here there's a lot wrong but
I'll point to just one thing this is the
commodification of human life
we are treating human life like a
product like like an item a thing to be
possessed and we're giving ourselves and
we're getting science a certain level of
control over human life that we
shouldn't have now you and I we were
born naturally right we we were born as
as the sorts of people that God or
nature if you like wanted or intended
but with this kind of technology if it
continues to expand and you see where
its leading people are going to be born
as the sorts of people that other people
wanted or intended them to be so this
seems among many other things and we you
know the fact that we don't know the
long-term effects and all that kind of
stuff but that's bad enough but this
seems to remove agency or removes
freedom from from a person kind of from
the very GetGo
take I mean even something like
engineering a certain eye color or hair
color for a child which is which is a
which is an ability that science already
has but even that as innocuous as it
seems I think is wrong is is really
wrong because if you think about like I
I have brown hair and I have brown eyes
right this is how I was naturally born
no human being
picked it out for me it's it's just this
is just me this is who I am this is just
how it ended up I would not want to have
brown hair because my parents wanted me
to have brown hair imagine that imagine
having some physical feature any
physical feature that is only there
because it's what your parents wanted
for your whole life you're gonna have
this physical feature you're gonna look
a certain way because it's what your
parents preferred but why should your
parents have any say over that at all
you're a person you're a human being
you're not a piece of furniture why
should your parents have it why should
they first of all why would a parent
have a
preference on what I color their child
is so you see already the parents that
engage in this kind of thing they have
it they have entirely the wrong attitude
about parenting they they see their kids
as accessories to their life the way the
same way that they would see a piece of
furniture or whatever like that you have
a preference of what kind of color it is
and all this all this sort of stuff but
in any case that's a human being why
should it be up to your parents what why
should why should I have a certain
physical feature because it's what my
parents preferred is the question and I
think that's where this is heading and
that's why it's wrong among all the
other problems but the the further that
we March with this technology the more
we get to a point where you know babies
are just as I said they're just kind of
accessories they're just they are items
that parents own and can even design to
meet their own personal specifications I
find that pretty horrific honestly now
before we wrap up I wanted to talk about
some positive scientific news yesterday
hopefully you were following this the
Mars insight spacecraft unmanned
obviously landed on Mars and this is
pretty incredible just just just imagine
building something that can fly off this
planet and travel whatever it is I think
it's a hundred million miles or so well
the the distance from here to Mars
fluctuates quite a bit but so I'm not
sure how far this thing traveled but you
know 100 million miles imagine building
something that can take off of our
planet travel a hundred million miles to
another planet land itself and then
spend years roaming around the surface
and studying it it's an absolutely
remarkable scientific accomplishment and
I just want to say this yesterday I saw
some people on Twitter on social media
complaining that well this is this is a
huge waste of money
you know we're wasting money by going to
Mars
and and and all of that what what a
dreary and dull and pitiful outlook on
life that you would consider that a
waste of money we we are exploring and
discovering and studying and going into
space that that's what we should be
doing at human beings that's one of the
things that makes us human is this drive
to explore and discover and humans have
been doing that from the very beginning
and and all along while you've had
people who are who are exploring and
discovering and innovating you've also
always had the dull kinds of people who
set off on the sidelines and fold their
arms and say oh it's too expensive it's
to this it's to that well it's a really
good thing that those voices are never
listened to because if it were up to
them you know we never would have
achieved any of this so I absolutely
think it's it's worth the money you know
not everything has to have an immediate
practical benefit yeah it's not like you
could say well what are we gonna do with
the information I don't know what do you
mean what are we gonna do with the
information that we get we're just we're
going to expand our knowledge we're
going to know more things isn't that
isn't that enough to expand our
knowledge and to know more about the
solar system and the universe isn't that
and do you need it does it does every
piece of knowledge that we gain does it
have to have some practical utilitarian
use in your everyday life and being a
more knowledgeable and well-rounded
person isn't that a practical thing in
and of itself so I think it's wonderful
I'm a huge fan of this and from what I
from what I've read NASA's plan is to is
to get us to Mars to get a human on Mars
sometime in the 2030s and I I fully
support it I think it's I think it's
worth every penny that we spend on it
and I very rarely say that about things
that the government does I'll just tell
you that all right we'll leave it there
thanks for watching thanks for listening
everybody Godspeed